Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians, thank you for waking up and for joining us
47 episodes!
With every episode, I feel like I just start yelling it louder and higher pitch.
Eventually, it's just gonna be... Eventually we'll thank you for joining us for...
Like that.
Well, we don't just make funny sounds, Ruffians.
No!
Especially Ruffians joining us for the first time today, we should probably explain ourselves.
Probably explain.
Yeah, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO-e!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO-e!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Did you get sleep?
Well rested, Ruffians?
Ready to bark with a new day?
Did we have maybe a Pero Sighting?
Well, you know, Pero, there was a video.
And, well, Ruffians, did you see Pero by any chance?
Let's see.
We have... De-den!
It's Pero!
You found him, Ruffian!
Maybe he's in better spirits after his vacation.
Maybe.
It looks like this Ruffian found him checking out the Miss Universe pageant.
Was he looking to enter it?
I see.
Pero.
You're not just there to look at the cute girls, right, Pero?
Right!
Maybe that's what he liked doing his vacation.
Cute girls.
That's awful, Pero.
Yeah, pretty nasty.
That's not what these competitions are for, you know.
Gosh.
Well, at least Moco-chan, he did get dressed up a little, right?
Yeah, I guess.
A little tie there.
It's good, yeah.
Well, we're glad you found Pero.
I guess, I guess.
At least, are all the Ruffians happy he's back?
Ruffians.
It's questionable.
Yes.
Well, at least you're happy he's back, I guess.
As long as the Ruffians are smiling, right?
Yeah, I'm happy that the Ruffians are happy.
That makes me happy.
But we still have more of a job to fulfill here, Moco-chan.
FUWAMOCO Morning continues!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for keeping your eyes open, Ruffians.
Even if maybe he's a big Ruffian.
But!
Happy New Year!
Yesterday, Ruffians, it was Nerissa's birthday!
Nerissa!
BAU BAU!
And it was, of course, her birthday.
It's a day full of celebrations.
That's what a birthday is!
But not only just that, because it wasn't just her birthday.
Also, because she hit 500,000 subscribers!
Congratulations, Nerissa!
We're so so happy for her and all the JL friends!
BAU BAU!
And you know, even on top of that, Nerissa released a new cover song of the opening theme of Elphelia and Lilium.
Did you listen?
It's something else!
This time, Nerissa's older sister, Anerissa, helped her with the low harmonies on it too, so it's not just Nerissa singing, it's also her sister.
For FUWAMOCO, it's kinda normal, but not for Nerissa.
That's really cool, right?
It's really, really cool.
Have you listened to Ruffians?
It's a really, really amazing cover.
It's very suited for her.
The demon of sound.
Even though some people say it's more angelic sounding.
I don't know.
I feel like it's more demon.
I feel like that.
Like, I'm going to go
It's gonna drive me crazy in a happy way.
In a happy way, right?
Like that, yeah.
That's what the demon of sound does, maybe a bit.
Actually, Ruffians, it was really just recently that we finally finished watching Alkaline.
Right!
We're glad that we watched it, but it was definitely something else.
It was something else.
Why did you think of the anime, Ruffians?
Did you watch it?
Maybe many years ago and FUWAMOCO just kind of late to the party.
Is it a party?
I don't know if it's a party.
Late to something.
A very interesting party.
It was something alright.
Intense.
Oh, intensely different.
It was an anime.
That's good.
That's a good statement.
Yes.
It was different.
But fun fact about FUWAMOCO.
Yeah, we've also sung in Latin quite a bit before too.
Are you surprised?
FUWAMOCO can sing a lot.
It's really pretty, so you know it's nice to hear Nerissa sing a lot too.
But, but, but, but, but, but!
Also!
Nerissa teased her upcoming first original song too!
Are you surprised?
We can't wait, Ruffians!
You know this, right?
She also shared with us her birthday wish!
It's released, but it includes a framed artboard, a t-shirt, a pin badge, and also a really cute ribbon-style keychain.
It's all included in the merch set.
It's Nerissa's very first birthday.
It's not sold out.
It's just the special limited edition version.
You can still get it.
The limited sold out, but...
I know it's a bit frustrating, but it's also, you know, happy for Nerissa's birthday, right?
But I really do love the keychain.
It just looks so cute and fashionable.
Just like Nerissa!
You know, it's kind of like a little piece of Nerissa that you can carry around with you, right?
It's pretty cute.
Put it on your bag, on your keys.
Where else could you put it?
Ruffians, do you have any ideas or places to put Nerissa?
Do you have a spot to put a keychain on your tummy?
Ruffians, that's weird.
And a birdhouse?
A birdhouse would be really good!
Yeah, I like that.
I guess they like shiny stuff, huh?
I think a birdhouse would be good.
Car keys, car keys too.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh well, there's lots of possibilities.
Yes!
Please check it out if you love Nerissa as much as we do!
BAU BAU!
What?
On the topic of a...
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Wow!
Ruffians!
Shiori!
Shiori released her 7-day cruise abroad!
It was really, really funny.
And really personal, too.
I feel like we got to see a bit more of what Shiori was like.
You know, she went on her cruise trip and we were like, Shiori, why?
Before FUWAMOCO, we never ever even dreamed of going on a cruise trip before.
No.
I feel like she did a rather good job of selling us on the fact that cruises are not for us.
Not for us.
No.
You know the idea of being trapped on a boat with thousands of people and only able to watch the performances and wait around in a pool and gamble and eat and drink.
I don't think it's for us.
No.
We're demon guide dogs, not cruisers!
Yeah, it was really cute.
You know it's very professional with like a shiori flavor.
Very, very cute.
Tasted like a bookmark.
What?
It tastes like a bookmark with a shiori flavor.
Oh.
Well, we hope that she makes more vlogs, yeah?
But we also want to stay close with her, you know?
Yeah.
Oh?
Maybe a solution would be that
We're taking an advent vacation trip somewhere all together!
Advent trip.
Would you like to see a vlog from something like that?
That would be so chaotic.
Are we sure we're gonna survive?
I don't know.
It'd be very, very chaotic.
What happens if we went to like a lake and then we like, you know, threw the rocks into the lake?
Yeah, yeah, like the, what's it?
The rock, rock throwing.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, we have more happy news!
There's also something very exciting happening!
This time there's no rocks involved.
No!
But there's watermelons.
Because FUWAMOCO Suiko got an O.K.!
And we just found out that FUWAMOCO has been included in the most- Yay!
No, they added IA and IDEA members, but they chose us to represent Alphys!
BAU BAU!
We're so thankful!
Is this the first FUWAMOCO appearance in a game?
Really?
Ruffians, you know.
You know, and also what we very much appreciate is that even though we are twins and we do have only one YouTube channel between us, we're tweeted.
We're treated as two different people, you know?
Because we're individuals.
I'm Mococo.
I'm Fuwawa.
Exactly.
So that really means a lot to us too.
It's important to us.
But, but, but!
Ruffians, do you also know what this club means?
We hope that you're ready for some more holo no Suika!
Yeah, cause we're gonna be playing it again sometime soon.
Sometime soon, you know.
Yeah.
It's been a little while.
We wanna play more.
Yeah.
I feel hungry for the holo no Suika.
We were just feeling like that the other day, huh?
Right!
It's the perfect time.
I really wanted to say thank you to Ponzu and TKT Games for adding us to the game too.
BAU BAU!
Exciting!
Great livestream probably not that soon.
Don't worry.
By soon enough, okay.
BAU BAU!
It's a good morning, right?
Lots of exciting things happening.
So many wonderful friends, too.
Having exciting things happening.
Very exciting times.
Happiness by osmosis.
And that's where it ends.
If for goodness.
Okay, Ruffians.
Ruffians!
You have to tell us something, okay?
You know that we've tried very, very, very hard recently not to make any more misunderstandings, right?
And you think we've done a good job, right?
We've done well, right?
Right.
We've been doing a good job, no more misunderstandings!
By the way, seeing comments being like, yes, you did a good job, Mococo!
Anyways!
This wasn't supposed to happen, but... It was Nerissa's birthday, right?
And of course!
We talked about it!
We wanted to get her a present!
But you know... People always like it when you make something special for them, right?
It was from the heart.
You know, so we did!
We did that.
We gave her a special FUWAMOCO birthday coupon.
Just like that!
Like that.
Yeah, birthday coupon!
Birthday coupon.
That's something normal.
You know, so that she can redeem it for one touch.
That's only one touch between the both of us.
Yeah.
Not one touch, Fuwawa.
One touch, Mococo.
No, no, no.
Only one touch.
Just one touch.
Yeah.
And you know, on the back of the coupon, it says, no ears, no tail.
No.
Yeah.
But, Ruffians!
Ruffians!
You've decided to erase Nerissa's name and put yours on it?
Huh?
What are you doing?
Oh my gosh.
No.
This is Nerissa's birthday gift for her.
Not yours.
No.
Can't do that.
Can't do it.
Can't.
Yeah.
And see, now, now Ruffians, you're printing the coupons out by the hundreds, by the thousands!
That's not okay!
No, no.
Oh my gosh.
Ruffians!
You know that's not how things work, right?
Right.
You know, I keep track of who gets coupons from me.
So you can't just pretend and try to fool me by saying that I would've made a ton of coupons like that!
It's special, okay?
It's just for Nerissa, you know it!
So you better be careful, okay?
We'll remember those who try funny stuff, okay?
I have a good memory, you know that.
I do too.
Even a better memory than Moco-chan.
Does it have to be a competition?
Got it?
Be careful, okay?
Watch yourself.
Yeah.
You won't get past the eyes of FUWAMOCO, okay?
Demon guard dog eyes.
BAU BAU.
Well.
Ruffians, you know how to behave now, right?
You know how to behave!
You always know how.
Know it!
Thank you.
That one Ruffian said yes.
They always have.
And I believe you.
I trust you.
I believe you, okay?
I believe you.
You'll behave too.
You'll behave.
Good, good, good, good.
You do your best honest.
That's good.
Maybe.
Maybe then.
If you're being good, which I'm not sure about, but if you're being good, then if you need a little bit of a push, maybe, maybe I'll give it to you.
Ruffians!
Good morning!
You're up!
It might still be dark out.
It might still be cold outside of your bed.
But, you did it!
Now, splash some water on that cute face of yours and let's get ready to make today ours!
You made it this far in the week, and that's amazing!
No matter how hard each day is, you keep going.
And you really need to give yourself some credit for that.
But also!
It's important to know when you need to give yourself a bit of time to rest and recover, okay?
Don't think of it as a break.
Think of it as another important duty to keep yourself going.
Okay?
But, do it.
Do also make sure to give yourself an actual break to do the things that you like.
It's an important break for your heart!
And you know, your heart is precious.
You need to keep it healthy, and safe, and warm up every day, okay?
Anyways, it's Wednesday!
The weekend is almost here!
Let's warm up the body for the day, warm up our hearts with a smile, and tackle the day!
You can do it!
I believe that you'll get past any obstacles you come across today.
Okay?
You're amazing!
You can do it!
Let's do it all together, okay?
Ganbatte da!
BAU BAU!
Let's do it all together today!
We have our Doggie of the Day next.
Doggie of the Day!
I want to see a cute doggy of today.
Well, we have...
De-den!
Morgan!
Today's Doggie of the Day is Morgan.
What's wrong with Morgan?
Oh well...
Morgan's kind of a bit gloomy because she doesn't like suitcases, you know?
She sees a suitcase, she says, oh my gosh, am I going to be left behind?
But that's not true!
Yeah, but it doesn't still stop her from looking like the saddest puppy ever.
You know, I can totally understand sometimes.
Does she need a hug?
I need to hug Morgan!
You know, I also want to rub my fingers down the caramel streak on her head.
You see right in between the eyes.
Me too!
Very cute.
Caramel streak.
Don't worry Morgan, it's okay.
Well, um, how does Morgan BAU BAU?
Maybe you know where she sees the suitcases?
Ah.
Like that. Maybe I don't know if we're capturing the sadness enough. That's good, that's good. Pretty good. You know, Morgan loves you and your little sister. That's what makes her dislike the suitcases so much. It makes sense.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians, have you been out and about going for walks?
Let's see, we have... De-den!
Wow!
It's another Mococo Sky!
I feel like we've had a lot of Mococo Skies recently.
I don't know.
It's just the Mococo Sky kind of time of year, you know?
Have I been missing out on calling every sky?
It's a Fuwawa Sky!
Have I?
Just because it's blue, you can't call it a Fuwawa Sky, okay?
I can and I want!
You can!
Ah, well, it's so pretty, you know?
Early morning walks are really nice.
Yeah!
The air is so fresh.
Fresh.
No one's around.
Ah, it's silent.
Right, the world is ready for you to discover.
Ah, it's just the birds.
As for us watching the sunrise, well, we see the sunrise, ah, we saw it last, yes, today!
Last, yes, yes.
When did we see it?
Today!
Yeah, we see it all the time, you know.
I like to watch the sunrise.
Yeah, especially mornings with the FUWAMOCO Morning, so... You know, sometimes, especially when you feel like, ah, I can't get out of bed, it's nice just to watch the sunrise or look outside at the sun.
And then you feel a bit better, okay?
And then there's the sometimes where you're like, looking really hard late at night.
And then before you know it, you look outside and you're like, why are you... Why is the sun here, hai?
Why'd you show your face here, hai?
Yeah.
Sometimes, sometimes.
This sometimes, sometimes.
Everyday sky is Fuwawa Sky.
Thank you!
And that sky is beautiful, right?
Right?
Right.
Fuwawa Sky is beautiful, right?
Mococo Sky is beautiful.
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day, we have...
De-den!
Hi, FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
Is there any preferred clothing or fashion you like to wear in winter that you don't usually wear in the other seasons?
We got this for a taste in fashion.
What?
So I'd like to see if you pass the test of this test.
Thanks for the saves, Fuwawa!
What do you mean?
This for your fashion?
We never said anything.
We just said that black and black isn't good, right?
Yeah, you want to be visible.
Especially in the winter.
Especially in the winter, you can't just wear all black.
That's dangerous.
That's dangerous, yeah.
But winter clothing!
Sweaters!
Wow, that was a lot.
Sweaters.
Yeah, sweaters are great because they're warm and comfy and fluffy and fuzzy!
They're cute.
Fluffy and fuzzy is good!
You know, they're extra cute, especially when, you know, they have turtle bags, or they have the moist sleeves!
You know, it's kinda long and...
It makes you feel more... You know, it has the vertical ribs.
Not horizontal!
Vertical ribs.
Say that again!
Say it again!
Vertical ribs.
What?
Not horizontal.
Vertical.
Yeah.
Yeah!
It's very cute!
Ruffians, you agree, right?
I did say vertical.
Vertical.
Hi!
We wouldn't want that.
We wouldn't, well...
What's going on, Ruffians?
What's going on?
Shiori is the word?
That's not the word I wanted.
But scarves!
Scarves are great too!
It's hard to find them, so sometimes it's best to make it yourself.
But I like scarves that are so long that we can both wear them.
One scarf for both of us!
It works well.
But it's very long.
Very long.
I think we passed your test.
You can't say we didn't pass it.
Peak fashion is when you wear a scarf for two people.
Got it!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for all your submissions, Ruffians!
Remember, we're always looking for more, so please use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Now for our next stream, we have De-den!
Today we're gonna be taking the rest of the day to
We need to make it special, Moco-chan.
It doesn't need to be special Ruffians!
Wait, is it okay if it's just... just us?
I guess that's a good question too.
Every stream is special!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Coughed up ASMR!
Just crunching, just crunching.
Why?
No just chatting, just crunching.
But we hope that you'll join us and that you'll be really happy.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, we talked about it a lot, but that's because this weekend is a big one for us!
We have a collab, our first collab with Rui-ne-senpai!
Because you know, it's twin day, and Rui-ne, she loves twins.
And we're twins, so we're gonna talk about twins on twin day.
But no pressure on Rui-ne-senpai to love us or anything, it's okay.
There's a lot of twins in Hawaii.
I don't know if we can fit that.
It might already be full.
It might be occupied.
But after that too, we'll be having a new cover song coming out, a FUWAMOCO cover song.
You know, and for us, these kind of times are very special to us, so we really hope that you'll be there.
To be like, wow, FUWAMOCO, this is exciting!
And listen to it.
Yeah.
Thank you.
We really put a lot of work into it, so... And we're gonna continue to put a lot of work into it until we're able to share it with you, so... Please look forward to it!
BAU BAU!
We're gonna do our best!
Thank you so much, FUWAMOCO!
Well, I have a good feeling about today, right, Moco-chan?
It's gonna be a good day.
It's gonna be a good day, so let's do our best!
Let's make it a good day all together, okay, Ruffians?
All together!
Ruffians, thank you for joining us for today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Aster.
BAU BAU!
Willow.
Reese.
BAU BAU!
Okami.
Colossus.
BAU BAU!
This boy.
Stick boy.
BAU BAU!
Asin.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!